Сейшельські острови в Індійському океані.
Зазвичай тут відпочивають
найвимогливіші та заможні туристи.
Серед них цього року був і генпрокурор України Юрій Луценко.
За даними журналістів програми "Схеми",
родина генпрокурора орендувала дві вілли з видом на океан
в одному з найдорожчих готелів Сейшельських островів.
Новорічні канікули обійшлися Луценкам
орієнтовно у щонайменше 52 тисячі євро.
Сам генпрокурор визнав, що лише проживання
утрьох коштувало у перерахунку близько
16 тисяч євро.
Втім, на екзотичних островах можна відпочити
і значно дешевше. Приміром, найдоступніший
готельний номер на двох з вильотом з Києва на найближчі дати
обійдеться приблизно у 3 тисячі євро на 10 ночей.
Однак в середньому, як зазначають українські туроператори,
такий тур коштує в межах 5 тисяч євро.
Ціни коливаются ще й залежно від пори року
та пакету харчування, але лише у бік збільшення.
Якщо враховувати, що середня зарплата
в Україні - 8 777 гривень,
то аби назбирати на такий відпочинок,
доведеться економити на всьому не один рік.
Адже навіть якщо не витрачати ні копійки зарплати,
отриманої за рік суми заледве вистачить
на найдешевший тур на Сейшели.
До середнього класу, як свідчать соцопитування
з відкритих джерел,
у 2014 році себе відносили
49% українців.
Проте соціологи наголошують -
часто люди вважають себе такими,
однак за об'єктивними показниками
не дотягують до цього рівня. Водночас за межею бідності,
за останніми даними ООН, живе
близько двох третин населення України.
Сейшельські острови - одне з найулюбленіших місць відпочинку для українського істеблішменту,
проте, виходячи з українських реалій,
залишаються дорогим і радше недоступним
задоволенням для представників
среднього класу в Україні.